[Music]
along with an ever expanding action
franchise is a prequels series a horror
series back for season 12 the final
hurray for a popular Netflix comedy
series and a scary movie it's all coming
up on this week's what to watch
to choose this life over friends
over family
conflict The Expendables 4. the first
reason to rejoin this fun franchise is
that it returns some familiar faces from
previous films like Jason Statham Dolph
Lundgren Randy Couture and Sylvester
Stallone and expanding on that or would
it be expanding are some fresh faces
including Curtis 50 Cent Jackson Megan
Fox and Andy Garcia and speaking of the
aforementioned slice alone another
reason it considered this movie is that
it marks his last go as Barney Ross the
leader of The Expendables Statham's Lee
Christmas is expected to take over as
leader for this and future films and
what a gift that will be fittingly it'll
be the gift that keeps on giving
Christmas all year my friends and
probably the biggest MF reason yeah I
did say MF is that the franchise is
moving back to the good old R rating
after number three went the PG-13 route
for the first time which backfired with
fans AKA it made less money and is the
only one with a poor audience score
every freak in that hotel will be after
[Music]
lovely
it's been a good way on peacock is this
week's the Continental this three-part
mini-series is a prequel set in the
world of John Wick the four film movie
franchise that is pulled in over a
billion dollars and built a strong fan
base along the way and probably resulted
in a few puppy sales too so yeah a
pretty convincing reason to try this one
another is that it goes back 40 years to
tell the story of how the Continental
came to be what we know it has today
that is an international Syndicate of
luxury hotels catering to Big Time
criminals where assassination
assignments are safely exchanged no big
deal along with a lot of coins and
thirdly in telling that story there will
be a couple of familiar characters that
includes one of the essential figures
Winston Scott played by Ian McShane in
the movies and by Colin Woodall in the
series and we'll see his right hand man
Sharon played by the late Lance Reddick
in the films and by ayomide atagun In
This his first ever role and it's worth
noting that Mel Gibson is part of the
cast as one of the main bad guys and the
one who was running the Continental back
in the 70s groovy man or was that the
60s
can I see the screen
one moment
do you want an Oscar
do you want it as much as a baby
yes horrifyingly and yet also gently
returning to FX is American Horror
's popular Anthology series and guess
what that's right all previous 11
seasons are fresh on the Tomato Meter
what an impressive first reason to add
this Horror Story to your list the
second reason is that some of the series
regulars are once again doing their
series regular thing like Emma Roberts
Billy Lord and Dennis O'Hare and joining
them are first timers such as Kim
Kardashian yes I did I did say Kim
Kardashian she's acting and Cara
Delevingne oh now I know you're
intrigued I can tell reason threes at
the story for delicate is based on the
new novel delicate condition by Danielle
Valentine it's about a woman who is
convinced that someone is going to Great
Lengths to keep her from getting
pregnant yet none of the men in her life
believe her and dare I say this will be
fresh season number 12 for American
Horror Story yep I do dare
anything for love oh I would do anything
for love
but I won't do premiering on Netflix
this week is the fourth season of the
comedy series sex education the first
three seasons of this popular show are
all certified fresh on the Tomato Meter
which is a certifiably good reason to
try this one out or stick with it
another reason is that the series which
revolves around Essex therapists
socially awkward son and his underground
Sex Therapy Clinic at high school finds
the main cast of characters going off to
college which leads to a whole new set
of challenges and a third reason is that
this will Mark the final season of the
show sad face emoji is there a sex Emoji
don't answer that but they are bringing
on shit's creek star Dan Levy to join
the cast as a college writing instructor
happy face emoji you can you can do that
one
there's something in here you can't see
it
but
it lives inside
and because at least two of your
neighbors have already put up Halloween
decorations hitting theaters is the
supernatural horror movie it lives
inside an interesting premise is the
first reason to scare yourself into this
one as it follows an American High
School girl in Indian origin who does
her best to deny her Heritage to try and
fit in until a friend is overtaken by a
demonic spirit and accepting that
Heritage is the only way to defeat it
Megan Suri is the star of this one
another great reason to check it out
considering she's already been in the
Netflix teen comedy never have I ever
and the Indie flick the miseducation of
Bindu and if you're just waiting to see
what the critics think wait no more it
lives inside is already hovering around
83 percent fresh on the Tomato Meter
with 25 or so reviews plenty more to
come talk about a fresh reason to go see
this one
well there you have it five picks to get
you all revved up for fall now all you
need is a pumpkin latte be sure to let
us end your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out rottentomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie in TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh